hi today I'm going to show you where I
work but before we do that and before I
show you how I accumulate I think I my
my profile at link I have saved about
15,000 words and phrases and my known
word count is up to 20 odd thousand and
stuff and I'll show you how I do that
but first I wanted to mention a little
bit about why it's fun to learn
languages I'm learning polish I'm
listening to filters podcast real polish
comm and he's talking about the Chopin
contest
in Warsaw a contest which he tells me is
takes place once every 5 years it was
won by a pianist from Korea Canadian
came second so my wife and I are sitting
here having dinner which my wife has
prepared and I said it wouldn't be nice
to see on our iPad a video of these
pianists from Warsaw so we're drinking
wine California wine we're watching a
Korean pianist excellent pianist playing
Chopin on our iPad as a result of having
studying studied polish and having
listened to Pyotr tell me that there was
this Chopin Piano Competition so anyway
it's just like this great global world
that we live in and we learned so many
things by learning languages anyway let
me short oh and the other thing I should
say is I've started speaking polish I am
using I talk e.com because we don't have
enough polish tutors at Linc and I've
had three sessions so far I've got
another one tomorrow
and I may in fact try to record one of
them so you can hear me struggling to
speak polish but now let me show you how
I accumulate all these saved words and
phrases and I'm learning so much about
the history of Poland the partition of
Poland the you know the Pilsudski and
the 20th century and all those kind of
stuff that I never knew before anyway
let's have a look so here I am I bought
this ebook called East
historia Polsky I have an audio book on
Polish history which doesn't match this
word for word but has a lot of the same
stuff so here's a lesson what we see
right away is that there's 223 blue
words that is words that I have not met
before most of which I don't know maybe
so if I click on that I see a list here
of all the blue words there are 289
links or words that I have already saved
many of which I know but not all of
which and these yellow words then show
up as yellow in my text and I go through
them and you know and so I tend to read
it to myself but the no you touch it the
cochise touch because nice touch Pop's
tower Luque like a gap miyanji from them
how much name apollyon
Jia Jia WA army booty onego the Russian
army but you need but eunuch Sam years
ions are intending now I know that word
I don't need it so I hit K so I don't
have to save it as dough [ __ ] revolve
okay
who does really hit yes poor giovanna
unexpectedly I know this word already
even though it's a yellow word I'm gonna
hit K this is not I'm not so familiar
thigh leave it dear VF Rosanna liver I
don't know what that is but if I'm not
sure that it's a word or a name I just
hit X so I don't count it in my
statistic now leverage speed law the
left wing I guess this is wing I know it
I hit k-e-t-v rear t wait I didn't
really know that so I keep that I keep
on hitting the arrow keys and it
automatically saves the word grows up
grows own grows house I know is
threatening so I can now remove that
from my savior growing draws on yay
o prozium I think that means to be
surrounded the word lab comes up in
Google Translate I could look that up in
a dictionary but I think it means to be
surrounded so I just gonna hit known
doesn't matter
oh yeah oppa dad SIA both operations
shape prophet Jonah conducted or carried
out and I leave the months all the times
it's so hard to remember the months who
dolly said now the hint that I get up
here is unsuccessful but that's Google
Translate in fact it means successful so
I had known screw chair touch me again
and I'll holla pre-build they always odd
CH or CH on now that's a word I don't
know even though I've encountered it
before I've already forgotten it so
basically just to show you I keep on
going through I review my that's a name
so I'll take it out of my save links and
here's another name which I don't save I
hit oh I hit K by mistake so I'll go
back not that it matters I'm not so
fussy about my statistics I hit X to
remove it sharpner RoSPA cinta started I
know that but I leave it there just the
same so that's how I go through quite
quickly finding new blue blue words or
this nah I know that September but I'm
leaving it because I find it
sheepish CPS Shinto vow are sealed I
sure don't know gold in general is reach
in store I know the word for victory so
I can hit K to remove it and that gives
you an idea of how I do it so as a
result of doing all of that over the
first two months of my a polish
challenge I have learned a great deal
about Polish history I have added
probably 20,000 words to my vocabulary
so it's built up this passive knowledge
and now tomorrow if I'm lucky I will
record my discussion with my polish
tutor on I talkie and you'll see how
much I'm able to use when I speak so
there you go a bit of an update on my
polish challenge thank you for listening